from minnesota headwaters
to the gulf of mexico
the ground runs with water
the lawn britt winters broken
window or
are not the fear
of colours floor spring comes to the
northern wilderness
resource of the river
late yesterday
randhir within minutes of a swing
the story begins
places than my norms of the business of
the itself
but it begins here
where the river begins
with a mailbox on the lonely norman
imperial
aren't going to win
bathed in wins and return currently
and something more
the in people along the mississippi
it
we wanted to go down the big river
himself
but instead
all through the long winter evening
zyuganov the small boat
larry and he didn't get a minute
correctly
there's a big deal
we went to spread into the bold
and within his big wintergreen
do you think it will make it
yes his brother
will people be too busy to bother with
it
few people will see that
dear or be remain noted ireland passage
through there paul
or perhaps a turtle
dance troupe destined to come over to
berlin
and then miles down the river through
red lights
long way to go
them flowing south
of down the great river valley
the american parklane
thousand four hundred wandering miles to
go
before it reaches the rivers and
and waiting hands
at the gulf of mexico
well it not
i could
how many years
if you're out what the in
it awfully it to the top
but no christian in minnesota pic
who who who might help is on its way
exactly
obviously rallied
that'd be great
i would him across the chalice batman
but when unhappy
there was a mason city
even mountain daylight time we were
playing cowboys and indians
none of us to be a probably around here
over your honest-to-goodness indians
chip away
like my grandmother now she speaks only
to flee he she wishes i spoken toward
mid-june
chipas mean a quiet day
which means he walks newt
badminton asking him to do
just like other kids
i_d_ playing baseball right now
except that take my father's once to him
lottery gap
driving factor in the timber
can you do not need to go down
came with u rapid
anyway
outside one of the stores on main street
indiana
weighing on the lovely uh...
leaving new to you
what our out of
he entered the new year bola ample
guided safely on his way
and hold on the extent of on every way
the mississippi leaves its chip away
friends
and that turkeys or weeks
believes the north country wilderness
no strange new sites
corporation
spending the river
industries
toning down upon our time you cried
please cities
crow wing
defaults
merced river china
minneapolis
dear robert de niro
therefore you're different voted him out
feeling in the river that's busy with
old balkan partisan great majors
stepping away each year after year
keeping the channel offered for
navigation
this is the river ira
for automotive repair
and here's how i first saw your guitar
board
seventy six
they found a property just about the
crime michael foale frustrating show off
down the river
my daughter tina and her friend billy
had come down to see me off
all cathy
i said goodbye to them
but although i didn't know if it
heidi deefaye goodbye to your fault
fourteen and feel had a plan
all right
how does it all
well robert best all your vessel got
tied on mine
anyway you're welcome to tag along with
asked all of the saint louis
down one of the richest river valleys in
the world
you are going down with a freight train
of the river
besides you or did you vote
navigating a string of oil barges wider
and longer than the queen mary
our first off by the way will be live
crosse wisconsin
one of our crew members peach on
it getting any better
peak claims he's not nervous but i've
got no idea he's doing a pretty good job
of covering up
just a lot with peter falk
p council arkansas
he's done long wait
told me about that
out everything you care and pointed out
to him considering
the rolling countryside in the way they
acquire
and that means that the people would
want to leave
plants and birds
karen everyday
but despite the wisconsin dairy barn
meet pete long to see cochran rolling in
art
don't like this
costumes for him
that hadn't been many people at the
wedding tools
kesi figured people just want very
friendly and that part of the country
what they mean
all of a sudden
wrong are you
feed pond
the people who have a mister french so
much pompous consent
alternate
somebody else around
hit the lottery old-fashioned weapons
the colin powell did
people in wisconsin
far too much different from phil simms
arkansas
but later that night
somewhere down the river from the cross
that what self-promoting uprooted tree
underlined your boat mapped
bogdan
another global bombing of the dog and
that property
see-saw of your digital
default
cannot repeat that
from mississippi in nineteen seventy
lakh
it was pretty big black hole i didn't
have a big economic
james french rather commands jeremy
hence krueger
amount of time you've gotten burned iowa
most of the people in this part of the
country came from germany a long time
ago
humans donations built his first we go
to
it's about a hundred years old
and you are indeed a river front street
and gotten back
country canada says it looks just like a
little germantown
but you can't prove it by me
because he knew the rivers one year
after another but it's kind of defining
land in iowa
packed up and i do know about
i'd just come home in time gettin
funding quote
hitler's dedicate
and just about every getting our family
got a deal
mother was going to happen
but i get mad
we're going to tel three ten
and heading out of the other hand
handicapped yet
anyway
really found a way to the debut punching
bag will have to get it
out
ethnic etc expedite
had fighting
any k
petrified
by
s but health are advising against all
the in order went down about what's
going on
that i have read carefully
can't wait
alcoholic
not much of a bold at work trying to
strengthen sa juneau
team on the way down from the beginning
of the news
if you've ever almost a thousand miles
let me
i see it
well i look at that
taking thank you
outside of my pocket by for eco koppel
okay outgoing that acne conference
aapan
why not put it on the pulse
emaina what might drop us on your balked
terrebonne these companies does not
detail if you put it on
adults are to be here both clover
panel help is going alright erection
action about that
at act
alright what are the expect dot
twelve headlight out there
you know went over to distribute to p
actually built he'd never heard
and why you can't take your time
for a week
told him about it
okay fellows go ahead
i wonder where you're going home
that has come from the minnesota
headwaters disdain
from saint paul to across
wisconsin river city
run across to debut on iowa shores
largest river city of them all
nerve center of the modern-day
city of santa creole levees
here
the mississippi poses
you know a little girl
whose great-grandparents journeyed over
land in the covered wagon
thais are towards decadent old
a dime store reminder of the river tom
sawyer mu
no from saint louis going down
deliveries river of a small southern
towns
bob carden
scorching summer sun
of eureka
hate sat down there
the robert iga
that was the first time my friend pat
soluble
we try to get it
but the levee got off to be
because i was taken away
it was pretty had for that time of year
your flood warnings out
crespo street italics day
we want to go disappeared
they say goodbye to each other
highland always been good friends
ever since we will ya
but lately we hadn't been seeing too
much of each other
can happen in the levee that day
they deflected your vote away
hierarchy and what happened
comes out of the statistics
but this year
sacred and i live
cataclysm
we had a little bit
slimy slightly
all right
garlic
look at me like
no he weighed
believe in that
there was your boat again robert
ourselves a primary holocaust
adware our lives
paintball
deal car
what top
my gag
what is it
can you plans
how did you get the balked so i watched
it about five points
dole actually all
well
i'm sarah rapid but i'm planning came
right now some other time
the worst part
coming out yeah
dole out of the exact words when paul
and i
wrangling
you see rabbit
we thought you might
here won't start arriving
together again
but there will be engaged when the blast
more river will seem without bail
vicksburg
and at last
with luck
new orleans bleak trading in
manufacturing center
river board brent ward of the world
frazier's loading for brazil
the indians
and it will be here
regard tiny craft will need all the bill
and it's a lot will hold
rolling up one of the reunion
carried down river
where three once more
huge drifts off course due to abuse to
displaying resourceful solutions which
hold cajun boys
prescription use like the
species
movie silently through louisiana by
users
here you
are both will need looks
excellent paul
ka
i wonder how much
failures
bring
tended to look will continue
in a lonely title date
but it was just be a up
first of all because we cut
but but but the well either way at all
costs
will see that he gets back
but on its way to the south pass
the channel to the cd
it passes adult replete
running the poorest all morning
tropical robert
and now it lives landmark
at him and saying
lost in the morning
oedema
for weeks one months ago
but didn't
lab inka dinka
alcohol willing
wall
but that is not a lot uh... mobilize
won't mean a lot
for one moment
barnwell go well
prominent warning in minnesota
two people along the mississippi
friendlier
where the rivers and
through the peoples of the world
nowhere is it though
and who will bring additional